bonsoir bienvenue dans le débat
politique week end le second tour des
élections municipales est fixée au 28
juin prochain
confirmation aujourd'hui du premier
ministre français après concertation des
partis politiques elle prématurée
faut-il reporter à plus tard
c'est notre débat ce soir avec lydia
guirous ce essayiste et ancien membre du
bureau politique les républicains
bonsoir lydia guirous ce nous sommes
également avec patrick mennucci ancien
député du parti socialiste et conseiller
municipal à marseille bonsoir patrick
mennucci merci à tous les deux de
débattre sur ce plateau ce soir
le scrutin aura bien lieu donc le 28 si
les conditions sanitaires le permettent
et sauf avis contraire du conseil
scientifique 5000 communes sont
concernées par ce second tour 16
millions de français sont appelés donc à
élire leurs maires
la vie démocratique doit reprendre ses
droits c'est ce qu'a dit edouard
philippe à matignon à la mi journée
écoutez le edouard philippe que l'on
entendra un petit peu plus tard un petit
problème technique
en tout cas edouard philippe a confirmé
cette date du 28 juin prochain
lydia guirous sais ce que c'est trop tôt
ou est-ce que c'est trop tard parce que
si on reporte à plus tard il faudra tout
recommencer
c'est encore trop tôt et un peu trop
tard c'est vrai que c'est assez inédit
d'avoir un second tour quasiment deux
mois après le premier tour
c'est un peu trop tôt parce qu'on est
aussi toujours dans l'état d'urgence
jusqu'au 10 juillet donc je sais c'est
entre deux et on reste dans la tente de
la décision qu'un jour avant du conseil
scientifique et en fonction de l'état
sanitaire qui aura en france mais c'est
vrai que la vie démocratique doit
reprendre ses droits
ça serait une élection qui sera inédite
puisque la campagne devra se faire
masqué dans le respect des gestes
barrières
c'est très étrange de faire une campagne
masques et de ne pas pouvoir faire de
réunions publiques puisque les
rassemblements la 10 personnes sont
interdites donc le gouvernement
recommande une campagne numérique mais
cela va être dur énormément de personnes
notamment les personnes les plus âgées
une campagne dans les médias mais on
sait très bien que l'attention va se
porter plutôt sur les grandes villes que
sur les petites villes donc c'est une
campagne qui va être assez assez inédite
et dont on se souviendra si elle a lieu
puisque pour moment reste quand même
dans la tente
la confirmation qu'un jour avant le
scrutin
qu'en pensez-vous patrick mennucci est
ce que c'est le bon choix le 28 juin ou
aurait-il fallu attendre davantage non
je vous réponde nos très clairement je
crois que c'est le bon choix
il faut permettre le redémarrage des
municipalités la vraie problématique
d'ailleurs sans doute que nos
concitoyens peu du mal à percevoir
c'est la question des intercommunalités
puisque il ya énormément de deux villes
qui ont été fournies au premier tour +2
81% mais il n'y a que 10 % des
intercommunalités c'est à dire
aujourd'hui dans notre pays les
intercommunalités c'est celle qui
investissent les grands projets sont
issus des métropoles des communautés
d'agglomération des communautés de
communes
et là il y avait une vraie difficulté
parce que vous aviez à la fois des
maires élus le 15 mars qui sont mis en
place ce week-end et puis des mères qui
avaient été élus en 2014 et donc il y
avait une énorme difficulté à faire
fonctionner les métropoles je pense
notamment à la ngp la métropole du grand
paris hier toutes ses déclinaisons
territoriales je pense aux grandes
villes évidemment à marseille à lyon à
bordeaux
à clermont ferrand à lille à strasbourg
amincie à m qui n'était pas fourni pas
plus d'ailleurs que rennes et nantes
et ce sont ces intercommunalités là qui
vont permettre notamment
redémarrage du btp et donc qu'il y a à
la fois une question démocratique
lydia l'a dit mais il ya aussi une
question économique et je crois que le
gouvernement après avoir pris me
semble-t-il les garanties scientifiques
est effectivement de revoir la chose
quelques jours avant l'élection
je trouve qu'il est tout à fait légitime
d'aller à l'élection le 28 juin
revoir la chose comme vous dites quinze
jours avant est ce que ça va pas faire
cours pour faire campagne imaginé une
campagne en pleine crise sanitaire je
vous propose d'écouter alexis corbière
de la france insoumise lui dit si a pas
de campagne
il n'y a pas de vote
actuellement à matignon au nom de la
france un soumise à propos du second
tour des municipales
j'ai exprimé notre désaccord total avec
la tenue d'un vote fin juin le comité
scientifique a indiqué qu'il ne sera pas
possible de faire campagne car dangereux
pas de campagne pas de vote comment
faire campagne
lydia guirous ce justement alors que
évidemment il ya beaucoup de problèmes
sanitaires pas de rassemblement pas de
meeting c'est une nouvelle façon de
faire campagne il va falloir réinventer
de nouvelles procédures et c'est aussi
le rôle des vues avancé de ce2 de
réussir à voir au delà des obstacles
pour que la démocratie guy donc je pense
qu'ils seront à s'adapter pour pouvoir
débattre faire vivre le débat
démocratique alors c'est vrai que ça va
être très très surprenant de faire
campagne avec avec un masque sans
pouvoir aller forcément dans dans les
marchés sont pouvoir tenir de réunions
publiques sans pouvoir faire du
porte-à-porte vont faire comment faire
comment faire aller sur internet alors
sur internet comme je vous le disais ça
peut ça peut toucher certains électeurs
mais pas l'ensemble des électeurs et je
pense notamment aux plus âgés je pense à
ceux qui n'ont pas accès à internet ya
quand même une fracture numérique dans
notre pays dans les médias et bien les
médias ne vont pas s'intéresser à tout
toutes les villes c'est c'est vrai que
ça va être une campagne qui va être
surprenante où il va falloir innover
mais comme le disait patrick mennucci
c'est aussi indispensable pour la
relance économique de notre pays parce
que si on ne relance pas
l'investissement public notamment
il y aura énormément de drames
économiques sociaux qui vont qui vont
arriver en cascade et et est vrai que la
situation est plutôt très inquiétante
donc il y avait urgence s'il ya installé
ses conseils municipaux pour pouvoir
relancer une partie de l'économie
patrick mennucci 56 % d'abstention au
premier tour vous pensez que ce sera
mieux au second a pas du tout non je ne
pense pas que ça sera mieux que je peux
et ça sera pire
je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de doute
qu aux citoyens qu'ils n'iront pas voter
mais je rappelle que la participation
le taux de participation n'est pas un
élément de la légitimité votre qui veut
vote qui peut il ya des procurations
qu'on peut faire il s'agit aujourd'hui
dit en passant ce qui nous écoutent
d'aller rapidement pour ne pas être
encombré au dernier moment dans les
gendarmeries dans les commissariats pour
faire à des procurations pour ceux qui
n'ont pas l'intention
ils ne peuvent pas se rendre aux urnes
le 28 juin
mais est-ce que génial j'ai dû me
réveiller un mot sur corbières je vois
sa déclaration
mais c'est de la pure politique
politicienne parce que si elle fuit les
insoumis avait fait une campagne au
premier tour ça serait légitime de dire
ce qu'il dit mais quelqu'un at il vu la
campagne de jean luc mélenchon aux
élections municipales le prouver tout il
n'ya pas une proximité patrick mennucci
vous savez bien d'accord mais quand on
regarde les résultats consolidés
elle fit fait 1,2 pour cent des voix ce
qui n'est évidemment pas le score de ce
parti dans le pays donc c'est vrai ce
que je veux dire c'est que lydia raison
la campagne de mme apparaître une
campagne habituelle va pas y avoir deux
meetings c'est dans les meetings par
ailleurs croyez en mon expérience et
quand vous avez dans une grande ville
comme orsay et quand vous arrivez à
avoir deux mille personnes c'est très
très bien et généralement vous n'avez
que des communes cuisse et donc pour
faire de la communication c'est légitime
d'ailleurs est normal mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer c'est une campagne qui va
être une campagne de réseau c'est une on
dit vous n'avez pas il va falloir aller
voir les gens avec un masque mais il va
falloir surtout travaillé avec des
téléphones il va falloir appeler les
électeurs les listes électorales sont à
la disposition des candidats
on sait qui a voté au premier tour qui a
voté au deuxième tour c'est la légalité
on peut aller à la préfecture les
relever
et ensuite il faut chercher ses
électeurs chercher leurs numéros de
téléphone et les appeler et je vous fais
remarquer que les listes qui seront en
concurrence le 28 juin sont des listes
qui ont réussi à passer le premier tour
ou qui ont été fusionnées ce sont des
jeunes qui ont une peau sans doute le
plus grande habitude que ceux qui ont
été éliminés c'est donc que nous allons
avoir un travail dans les grandes villes
qui va peut-être une travail politique
de proximité mais qui va se faire avec
des téléphones
voilà je pense que en tout cas pour
avoir discuté avec quelques candidats
qui s'apprête à faire campagne dans les
jours qui viennent
ça va sans doute être ça il va être fait
le plus pour obtenir le soutien des deux
acteurs on se souvient évidemment de la
polémique après le 15 mars après il ya
le confinement lydia guirous c'est cette
question fallait-il déjà organisé ce
premier tour étant donné le fait que la
france n'avait pas de masque qu'elle
n'avait pas test afin qu'elle n'avait
pas du tout les les mesures sanitaires
adéquates
même si aujourd'hui elle les a est-ce
que cette polémique a lieu d'être encore
écouter edouard philippe il a dit
j'assume ce matin j'assume surtout cette
décision parce que dans aucune
démocratie on ne peut décider en dehors
de tout cadre légal d'annuler un scrutin
la veille du jour où il doit se tenir
alors on va pas revenir sur cette
polémique mais c'est cette même question
qui se pose finalement pour le second
tour il y ait eu des morts des maires
sont morts après après l'organisation du
premier tour qu'en pensez-vous du virus
dont il se sort risque finalement et et
et quantifiables et est à prendre pour
des raisons de démocratie et des raisons
économiques selon je pense que ce qui
n'a pas été compris pour le premier tour
c'est qu'on terme les restaurants les
cafés à la veille du premier tour en
mettant un message d'alert assez
angoissant d'ailleurs mais en appelant
en même temps à aller voter ce qui était
assez contradictoire c'est ce que les
français n'ont pas compris et d'ailleurs
il ya eu un très fort taux d'abstention
notamment chez les personnes les plus
vulnérables et les plus âgés aujourd'hui
on a un peu plus de recul on a plus
d'équipements donc on aura les masques
qui sera obligatoire il y aura le gel
chacun doit apporter son stylo certaines
de ces mesures étaient déjà mises en
place dans les bureaux de vote il ya eu
énormément d'assesseurs deux présidents
de bureaux de vote certains maires
également qu'ils sont tombés malades
voire qui sont morts ce que je crains
pour ce second tour c'est qu'on ait du
mal à trouver les assesseurs et les
présidents de bureaux de vote
les gens ont encore en mémoire le
premier tour ça sera à l'état
d'organiser ça peut-être en
réquisitionnant des fonctionnaires mais
je pense que nous avons les moyens
d'organiser ce second tour dans des
conditions sanitaires qui feront prendre
un moindre risque pour pour les
participants et pour ceux qui
l'organisent patrick mennucci on entendu
le premier ministre dire j'assume
il a fallu qu'il tranche aussi le
premier ministre cette semaine puisque
ils renvoyaient la balle aussi aux
partis politiques
c'était compliqué à prendre cette
décision alors le premier ministre il
est fait de la politique et il oublie
beaucoup de choses quand il dit j'assume
et on annule pas une élection à la
veille du premier tour
je crois qu'il a raison simplement comme
le disait lydia en même temps qu'on
annule pas l'élection on interdit aux
gens d'aller au restaurant mais la
vérité citer que l'annulation de
l'élection alors et dieu et d'intervenir
probablement le jeudi quand le président
la république fait son intervention
c'est à ce moment là je crois qu'il
fallait le faire c'est certain que le
samedi à la veille de l'élection c'était
trop tard
moi ce qui me paraît important c'est que
ce qui pouvait être craint c'est à dire
que compte tenu des très mauvais
résultats de la république en marche
c'est à dire du parti du président la
république et des soutiennent d'edouard
philippe certains imaginer que le
gouvernement allait repousser les
élections pour essayer d'avoir une
deuxième chance
moi je salue le fait que cela n'ait pas
été fait et que le gouvernement alors
qu'il sait qu'il a un certain nombre de
ses soutiens qui seront très grande
difficulté maintien élections je pense
notamment ce qui va se passer à
strasbourg où le principal exploit de la
république est en marche de conquête a
été balayé au premier tour je pense à
nancy où monsieur hainard est en très
grande difficulté face au candidat du
parti socialiste soutenue par les
écologistes ou à montpellier où le l'ami
du président la république monsieur sort
elle a toutes les chances d'être battu
par michaël delafosse donc il faut
souligner que le pouvoir politique n'a
pas pris en compte des questions
politiciennes pour prendre sa décision
compte tenu de ce que chacun sait de ce
que je pense de ce gouvernement
je salue toutefois saas sur l'attitude
démocratiques et républicaines cette
affaire j'aimerais qu'on écoute
christian jacob a à présent le président
les républicains à l'assemblée nationale
je vous fait réagir il a parlé de la
polémique cette semaine du fait que
justement l'exécutif consulté les chefs
de parquet pour prendre cette décision
ce qu'il n'avait pas fait pour le
premier tour et coutelle le président de
la république et le premier ministre ne
veulent pas assumer la décision qui est
dans la loi que eux mêmes ont fait voter
au parlement je sais pas si ça cache
détention d'ailleurs entretien on reste
sur la base de la loi les choses sont
relativement simples à christian jacob
qui disait en gros il faut prendre une
décision puisque c'était pas gagné cette
semaine il ya guy roux ce le fait
d'avoir consulté les partis finalement
ça met tout le monde d'accord allait
consulter les partis c'est une décision
je pense qu'on peut pas prendre
les différentes forces politiques les
différents partis et christian jacob a
raison il faut moment tranché il faut de
la clarté pour qu'on puisse se projeter
s'organiser et faire en sorte que ces
élections aient lieu d'un dans les
meilleures conditions et que et qu on
ait enfin des merdes et des conseils
municipaux des communautés de communes
qui puisse se faire le relais du plan de
relance que va faire que mettre en place
le le gouvernement donc c'est et c'est
une bonne chose que la décision soit
prise même si que sont encore attendre
15 jours avant pour avoir une véritable
confirmation de la tenue de ce second
tour
gouverner c'est choisir c'est ce qu'a
dit également un christian jacob patrick
mennucci si ce second tour ne se faisait
pas le 21 juin c'est quoi le scénario
c'est tout recommencer après on va
écouter c'est très simple lydia faisait
allusion à la loi du 23 mars 2020 c'est
au fond assez simple en france la loi
dit que le deuxième tour a lieu le
dimanche qui suit le premier donc ce qui
n'est pas fait dans ce cadre là n'est
pas constitutionnel donc
compte tenu de la situation et de
l'urgence la loi qu'ovide du 23 mars qui
prend beaucoup d'autres questions
sanitaires mais aussi cette question là
dit comme le disait d'ailleurs christian
jacob précairement si l'élection a lieu
avant le 30 juin
eh bien on peut estimer que le premier
et le deuxième tour sont reliés malgré
le fait qu'il y à deux mois et demi
d'écart si on devait dépasser cette date
c'est à dire il faut bruit voté le 4
juillet comme ça a été aussi envisagée
il faudrait à ce moment-là refaire les
deux tours mais cette affaire-là n'est
pas terminée le gouvernement fait voter
il a raison mais vous aurez devant les
tribunaux administratifs et de
détaillants et les recours seront
d'ailleurs réglé non pas par le conseil
d'état mais par une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité qui sera adressée
au conseil constitutionnel à la demande
des requérants devant les tribunaux
administratifs et c'est là qu'on saura
exactement dans six mois ou d'un huit
mois si les règles les formes ont été
entièrement respecté ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que les formes
politiques sont respectées est-ce que
les formes constitutionnel le faut bien
souvent les équipes c'est laurent fabius
et le conseil constitutionnel qui auront
à le dire dans les mois qui viennent à
la roquette de ce qu'ils contesteront
les élections ici ou là merci beaucoup
patrick mennucci ce sera le mot de la
fin merci beaucoup les virus d'avoir
participé à ce débat le débat politique
du week-end